welcome to the game 15 minute game again
here on icc played in the 15-minute
rapid pool and an idea 3b6 so i could
actually play you for here transposing
to an e4 kind of setup let's see what
happens okay he just plays some for a
double fianchetto yeah I guess some I
should just them develop and take the
center him yeah like most likely okay he
doesn't I wanted to to say well on opt
for the Sun hippopotamus setup was e66
and so on but he just played Knight f6
okay I cut down play Bishop d3 cover the
porn or I Tekkit I take the night I
think I'll do that should win some space
hmm
yeah okay don't want him to take my
bishop here and I might be able to
simply play 83 king the Queen d2 and
winning for the 10pm on this on this
night on g4 which frankly speaking is
some just a weird piece it has some
no-good squares I mean this move might
okay make sense of what was with g6 on
something similar coming but no h5 has
some hard too hard to understand I mean
okay wants to go to age 6 foot it's not
not brilliant Edom okay so what should I
do the bishop boom on f1 is not
developed yet and it has two possible
squares b3 and ce4 id3 and c4 c4 might
allow some player again step 7 but d3
it's also not without its points so that
in case you moves too deep on a half the
movie 6 so the bishop on d3 is working
against the street six point I think
I'll go here but it's hard to how to
evaluate Bishop c4 wasn't turn bad
certainly yeah I thought this wasn't
possible actually because of a six
okay so now I've got multiple option cm
now G to f7 is not them yeah I'm not
terribly sophisticated idea but it might
might be good he's got Bishop default
though possibly not not in this exact
position because of Bishop b5 but the
snider three leaf sound the deep one
unprotected ok what else at them night
to each for us also also possible a team
with the idea of just taking g67 you
cannot cover it there's just the move
Queen c8 available or night eh form so
nigh g6 Queenie 60 is coming
yeah how to determine them so at some
very attractive position obviously also
just Queenie too it's not bad at all
improving the position go and prepare
long castles yeah maybe on light g5 he
will play quincy aid i'll just complete
my development first okay my disposition
must be flat-out winning for white this
cannot be playable with with this porn
only 695 f6 and black has a position
full of weaknesses but white has so yeah
a whole bunch of good moves and
sometimes it's not so easy to determine
what what move of all this good moves is
actually the best one or the easiest to
play so it's often easier to play if you
have a bad position because you if you
have just one move on your Jeff just
have forced moves castles
so should I just cancel myself now
complete development you know think the
sum should be a ride
so what would you play now maybe knight
c6 taking deform yeah maybe
okay so taking default straight away
with the with porn so
okay don't want to spend too much time
getting in turn it into some time
trouble later okay not to have six so
should I go nite h4 now directly going
against this g6 porn yeah come on King
age seven I can just play G find this
this this wouldn't this doesn't hold I
mean no kg form gives away the rook for
the bishop room but no way that this is
playable for Black walking age seven
maybe maybe can take on g6 and play G
for something like this this may be even
stronger yeah this is stronger yeah I
don't see a move all right you can try
to UM Cavill with Quinn g6 or try okay
place this one so the question is now
should I play I mean so play G for night
f 596 all three moves look I'm pretty
devastating
if i take g6 King takes g4 threatening
Bishop takes a 5 checkmate so he might
need to move the king again 2h7 maybe
and then I can play also g5 the other
move that was my initial idea actually
was G form yeah also cannot believe this
ok cannot take with any porn hghg if the
H file is open with deadly threats if he
takes with the f porn i'm just taking g6
and win I think I mean black needs to
take on h1 first two at lease them get
some yeah material for a sweat position
now that I look at it may be 94 okay
something else entirely how to how to
play is just playing something entirely
different than what I expected okay what
can I do I can take c4 just objects of
takes f5 on gtx FG five
also not bad at all okay come on don't
spend too much time yeah this just
threatens to take on f6 and then on h5
with a very strong attack
whenever he moves the night I might have
g6 check and Quint XH 500 on a very
dangerous position for like okay so
should I take f6 now yeah probably he
needs to take with the rook also if it
takes with the bishop between age 5 is
just winning rook g1 next move so he
needs to play rook rook h6 and now queen
takes a try for do I have a better move
even yeah I think I should take just to
prevent also Queenie 8 and what now is
there a better move than taking on h1
after which I would have yeah office
strong compensation but not sure if I
maybe I can do better not losing a tempo
yeah but maybe this this piece will be
some counter play also so just take it
yeah now I just want to play rook g1 and
died f5 something like this and win on
2g file i also have 95 coming up
okay maybe just rip g1 it belongs on g1
anyway so not think too long here the
only concrete threat has night x at five
just then forcing okay I thought night
d5 here would be would be rather strong
not quite sure if he can move the rook
even roughly six I have at least 97
talking both rocks but night f5 essa is
even stronger I think okay so he wants
to I quite sure what he wants 96 maybe
if I take on on f6 and he recaptured
with the Queen he has some as a threat
on be too so
yeah multiple options very nice very
nice position I cannot so just take f5
with the night route cakes Queen takes
Queen takes that 597 check group King
moves 905 should be some advantage but
maybe it's not not an outright win and I
think I want an outright win here Bishop
g5 maybe Bishop g5 s also not bad at all
don't see move really Bishop g5 rookie
six I can just take each seven
take you seven year two times and then
night f5 at the end and it's it's over I
think okay so on rookie six I just
capture e7 with and night rook takes
Bishop takes Queen takes and night f5 it
takes the Queen only seven and double
check with not on f5 Andrew kanji one
against the g7 bishop so I should win at
least the Queen 44 rock in peace maybe
there was something better even so look
so loss for black I mean we have also
bishop age you should 86 I could could
have played also yeah but now I thought
just Bishop f6 and night f5 this this I
cannot believe that this should hold so
just night f5 now also threatening
knight to e7 winning the house and also
not h6 threatened night h6 require King
move and then I've got a discovered
shaky okay this one's the Queen iam do I
have something better okay so yeah first
take the Queen you can always give
checkmate later
black resigns yeah i think this this
opening was simply not not playable this
looks rather weird with them 4km this is
really a really awesome bit too much to
allow this here okay maybe here not c6
multi-plate castles long castle and c5
you know i mean i cannot really believe
that that black and play this time maybe
a computable tamiya it is playable but
I'd I simply don't get it okay but
here's an interesting here's an
interesting position um I played this
which is quite okay i think but um i
would be interested on to look quickly
at 96 which also looked very nice yeah
here i forget i forgot about this I was
only thinking about this move which
isn't so clear really but gasps stupid i
can i can just take here also and this
is this is getting funny now this is
physiol queen III so um cannot do this
I've got this checkmater sharian okay so
on whoops so this this and tennis takes
g4 so you need to need to go back
opening the age health cannot help and
then this one yeah okay I see and now I
need to need to to block this this is
this here
with with the piece and then this is
just deadly with those this night having
multiple threads all right so 96 green
was even quicker but I think g4 is also
yeah the conv also gives us S Plus 2 or
something yeah this he tells us isn't so
clear actually it's okay then the humans
are now is now is going to plus 2 also
so this move was also okay at least them
technically takes takes rook you yeah
here wants to play a g6 okay it's also
good move I didn't mention this even but
this is yeah this is just as good the
computer is on plus 9 yeah okay this
this kind of opening is just not not
playable you need to put something in
the center and you cannot provoke wide
advancing here like place e66 now this
kind of hit bottom a setup it slightly
progressive but certainly a playable
position yeah thanks for watching